or in other words, we
can run it in reverse.
To illustrate how this works, let's imagine that we first run R and then we run R in reverse,
which we can express as R dagger.
To be clear about this, what it means is that we apply the gates
of R in the reverse order and we take the inverses
of each of the gates.
NOT gates, controlled NOT
gates and Toffoli gates are actually their own inverses, so if we're thinking in
terms of these gates,
then R dagger is really just R with the gates supplied
in the reverse order.
But in general, we can always run any unitary quantum circuit in reverse in the manner that I just described,
meaning that we apply the
gates in the reverse order and we replace each of the
individual gates by its inverse.
If we were to do this, we'd find that first running R and then running R in
reverse does nothing at all.
So if we started out in a standard basis state like we have here, then we would end in exactly the same standard basis state.
Of course, doing just
that isn't very helpful, but what we can do is we can introduce a bunch of extra qubits and specifically,
this is M qubits where M is the number of output bits of the circuit C.
These additional qubits could
be in any quantum state, but to explain how this works, we're going to assume that they're in a standard basis state
corresponding to some string Y. So Y is an M-bit string, and what we can do is to perform
a bunch of controlled NOT
gates like you see right here, which effectively XORs the string F of X
onto the string Y stored
in these bottom M qubits.
And so the output of
the entire computation is as it appears on the screen.
X and Y are arbitrary binary strings. X has M-bits and Y has M-bits, and we also need K workspace qubits.
When we run R, we compute F of X and that string is stored
in the top M qubits, but we also have a
bunch of garbage qubits,
so we XOR the output F of
X onto the bottom M qubits and then run R in reverse
to clean up the garbage.
I should point out that it's important that R is deterministic.
If these top M qubits could be instead in some superposition of
standard base of stats, this wouldn't work correctly,
but this does work when
R is deterministic.
So if we compare the quantum
circuit we just built to the original Boolean circuit C, we see that it basically
works in the same way
that a query gate works
for an arbitrary function.
There is a difference here, which is that we need
these workspace qubits to make it all work, but otherwise we've
effectively built a query gate
or a query circuit for whatever function it is that C computes.
We also managed, by the way, to return the workspace
qubits to their initial state, so they could in principle be reused
as workspace qubits for
subsequent computations.
If we want to, we can put a box around the entire quantum circuit and call it Q and the relationship to
C becomes more clear.
The circuit Q will be
bigger than C in general. We need a handful of quantum
gates in Q for each gate of C,
and we also need the controlled
NOT gates in the middle, but the number is still
linear in the size of C.
It should also be noted that this is a completely general procedure which works for any Boolean circuit, and we haven't tried at all to optimize Q.
For a specific circuit C, there might very well be
ways to reduce the size of Q, and that includes using methods
that reduce the number of
workspace qubits needed in case that's something
that we want to do, and that is the procedure for running
classical computations
on a quantum computer.
It's pretty simple, but it's an important
thing to be able to do.
In particular, now that
we know how to do this, we are free to make use of any classical computations we want
inside of quantum computations, provided that we follow this form where the input gets echoed and the output gets XORed
onto a bunch of qubits
just like we had for query gates.
The cost scales linearly. So for example, we can
create quantum circuits for problems like integer addition,
multiplication, division, computing GCDs and modular exponentiation, and this can all be done at the same asymptotic cost
as for Boolean circuits.
We do need workspace qubits to do this, but at least they're available to be reused again when
we're done with them.
One final remark that's worth mentioning is that this method provides us with a method to implement query gates,
which I alluded to in the previous lesson.
That is, if we have a query algorithm that takes some function F as input, and we have a way to compute
F with a Boolean circuit,
then we can follow this procedure to build a query gate for that function and then run our query algorithm on it.
Whether or not that's a useful thing to do depends on the query problem itself and what we're trying to accomplish, but in essence, this
construction provides us
with a way of connecting the query model to a more standard model of computation.
This is in some sense how Shor's algorithm for integer factorization works.